two senior schools the King Edwin school
and the Swain Park school joined
together to help the Chairman host his
guests and raise money for charity with
a tasty afternoon tea and an array of
music the Chairman enjoyed a visit to
the Great Wakering summer play scheme to
find out what was in store for the local
children the place scheme had a wide
variety of fun activities on offer he
also went along to see the Beavers cubs
and scouts of the district renew their
promise and to join in with a sing-along
around the campfire the Chairman also
met the newly formed beaver Scout colony
from canoe j'en if you feel someone
deserves an award then the chairman of
Rochford District Council wants to hear
from you extraordinary people of all
ages who even though they may not seek
it truly deserve recognition the awards
are made by Rochford District Council to
recognize and acknowledge individuals of
the district for their valuable hard
work or outstanding achievements the
awards will honor those who may not
normally be recognized for their efforts
please remember that nominations are
open to all including those whose
achievements haven't been recognized in
previous years all nominations will be
considered by the judging panel and
winners of the three categories will be
selected an overall winner will also be
chosen from the three category winners
and the categories are young citizen
under age 18 charitable support all age
groups community spirit again all age
groups the overall winner will be
invited to attend the annual civic
dinner held in March to be presented
with their award by the chairman of
Rochford District Council to invite the
chairman to your event or for a
nomination form for the citizens of the
Year award phone 0170 2318 144 or email
Julia Mitchell at Rochford gov dot uk'
rochford district ops recycling league
residents in rochford district are the
best in England when it comes to
recycling that's the verdict of the
government department who monitors waste
and recycling figures statistics
released by the Department for
environmental food and rural affairs
defra in November placed Rochford
District Council at the top of the
league with a huge recycling rate of 65
point seventy nine percent putting us
first out of more than 350 local
authorities across England it means that
residents across Rochford district
recycle and compost more materials than
anywhere else in England and are the
best at ensuring as little goes to
landfill as possible meaning a greener
future for all since 2008 Rochford has
gone from being one of the lowest
performing local authorities in the
country for recycling and composting
with a rate of under twenty percent to
the best and it's all because of the
commitment shown by residents to
recycling and composting as much as
possible Christmas bin collection dates
the normal collection date monday the
26th of December will be Tuesday the
27th juicy the 27th will be wednesday
the 28th wednesday the 28th will be
thursday the 29th thursday the 29th will
be friday the 30th and friday the 30th
will be saturday the 31st monday the
second of January the third of January
the fourth of January the fifth of
January and the sixth of January we'll
all be as normal
the council will be installing its first
we which is waste electrical and
electronic equipment recycling bank in
the district in the next few weeks it
can be found in back main Rochford
alongside the other recycling banks and
is for the collection of small battery
operated or plug-in household electrical
items such as kettles toasters and hair
dryers the facility does not allow for
large items such as fridge fridges
freezers and televisions if you want to
recycle these please call customer
services on 0170 2318 one double one to
arrange a bulky waste collection or they
can be taken to the recycling center for
household waste in Castle Road rayleigh
now the opening for placing items in the
bank is only large enough for items such
as the ones we're going to tell you
about if you visit the bank and find
your item is too big please take it to
the recycling center for household waste
or take it home with you any items which
are left be hot beside the bank will be
classified as fly-tipping now what they
will accept are these shavers hair
dryers hair straighteners toasters
kettles mobile phones games consoles DVD
players radios ions lamps without the
bulbs chargers computer hard drives
cameras power tools and food mixers what
they cannot accept fridges freezers
televisions washing machines tumble
dryers laptops batteries on their own
light bulbs fluorescent tubes vacuum
cleaners computer monitors or microwaves
please note there are household battery
recycling containers located in the
reception areas of the council offices
at Rochford and rayleigh and at all
libraries across the district don't
forget that council offices are always
on hand and ready to advise you on which
items can be recycled if you have any
queries about which I
tips can be placed into the new we bin
or any other recycling bank or bin then
you can call our customer services team
alternately you can go online to check
which items go we're on our special
recycling a to Zed feature on the
website you can find it at wwt a govt UK
/recycling a to Zed many of you may
choose to have real christmas trees this
year and if so you'll be able to dispose
of them by cutting them down and placing
them in your compostables bin please be
aware that we can only accept trunks or
branches which are less than 30
centimeters in diameter anything larger
please take to the recycling center for
household waste in Castle Road rayleigh
we asked you if you love where you live
and we were overwhelmed with the
response over the last few months local
groups have organised litter picks
family fun days and information events
rochford district youth council have
litter picked at Grove woods in rayleigh
and joined the Friends of Sweyn park
open space and other volunteers on their
autumn litter pick rayleigh town council
also organised a litter pick of the
town's King George the fifth playing
field it's not all about hard work
though the Friends of Swain park open
space and the Friends of cherry orchard
Jubilee Country Park have held events
where people could have fun and learn
more about their local open space if you
want to organize a litter pick in your
area the council can help by loaning
litter pickers providing bags and
collecting the rubbish from you after
the event to find out more about how you
can get involved call 0170 2318 one
double one
a number of changes have been made to
the recycling bank sites across the
district over the past few months the
main change being sites no longer have
separate recycling banks for plastic
bottles tins and cans and food and drink
cartons new bins will be added which
accept all of these items in one bin I
list now all of the recycling bank sites
throughout the district and the
materials that can be recycled their
paper mixed glass textiles food and
drink tins household plastic packaging
and cartons golden cross parade and
ashington community center both
ashington road ashington canoed and
village hall lambourne haul road
culloden great wakering sports center
high street great wakering clements
[ __ ] leisure center Clements hallway
hawk wall South End Road car park south
end road hockley Paul's lane car park
pulls lane hullbridge Roura the playing
fields r oriflamme Roura 'the fairview
playing field victoria road rayleigh
webster's way car park in rayleigh and
back lane car park in rochford for paper
glass and textiles only foulness island
village hall found s island and the
freight house rochford mixed glass only
the Shepherd and dog pub includin
balance core golf club in kinnunen the
White Hart pub in Great Wakering the
White Hart pub in Hawk wall the bull inn
at hockley the Royal British Legion in
hockley the castle in pub in florin mill
hall in rayleigh and rarely town sports
and social club in rayleigh for paper
and textiles only Hopley woods car park
hockley and the royal oak in great
stanbridge textiles only ball woodhall
prison hockley and for paper only sent
pieces mission hauppauge awesome the
White Horse pub in rochford and Romney
house ApS oast way Rockford for further
information please contact customer
services on 0 1 702
318 one double one or email customers
services at Rochford gov qk